you're a kind of therapist or you have
the power
to be a therapist
i don't mean just about the medical
condition of the body but the
psychological there's so much fear
connected uh to to this concern
also uh self-doubt
um
insecurities
even uh sort of existential thoughts
about your mortality all those things
are right there in the room
um so i think one way doctors deal with
that is they kind of have this cold way
about them they almost have to do a mode
one is like i'm going to be friendly on
the surface
and cold about the
brutal honesty of the biology
but i wonder if there's like um
a skillful middle ground
this dangerous place where
you can help people deal with their
psychological insecurities concerns
fears all those kinds of things is that
just really tough to do
yeah it's it's a huge part of being a
doctor is is dealing with the
psychological aspects of whatever is
going on with the patient's body i mean
in the er you deal with psychiatric
emergencies kind of left and right more
than ever these days and um you know
that's a huge issue not to mention sort
of drug use alcohol related stuff you
know that gets into sort of psychology
and the human love of intoxicants and
changing the brain's chemistry
um and you know inhabit of course we're
creatures of habit and that plays in as
well i mean a big part of for instance
pediatrics is reassuring parents and
kind of convincing them
giving them the confidence that what's
going on with their child is not serious
will go away on its own does not need
any particular intervention
um and but adults too you know
reassurance is a huge part
of the game um
yeah you know in the er you see humanity
at its most raw i feel like you get this
tremendous insight into people
how they live what they worry about what
they think about how their body works
and also how their mind works that you
almost don't see anywhere else it's a
really interesting um place to work and
also the way our society is shaped the
er is where people go for almost
everything when they're suicidal they
come to the er when they're too high on
drugs to walk they come to the er you
know children who have been abused
sexually abused physically abused come
to the er for us to investigate
uh it's sort of like the the all-purpose
waste bin for the dregs of society what
people do to themselves and what they do
to other people you know you mentioned
you're interested in the darkness of
humanity it made me think of the er
where you really see
uh what human life is like um in the er
okay you've uh you tweet about you write
about you think about the emergency room
er
that's really fascinating
just a little window you uh give to that
world it's fascinating
what
lessons about humanity do you draw
from this
place where you're so near to death
there's so much chaos
there's so much variety of what's wrong
so little information
um or the
the the urgent nature of the
information inflows such that you can't
really reason
sort of thoroughly and deeply and
collect all the data all those kinds of
things you have to act fast and then
everybody's freaking out can you just
speak to the human condition
[Music]
that you get a glimpse at
through the er experience
yeah i think you do see all those things
i think on on one end of the spectrum it
is this very unique place where you get
all these unique insights on the other
end it can become a ho-hum workplace
just like any other which is sort of
surprising as i mentioned before humans
seem to be able to get used to almost
anything
and doctors can get ho-hum used to oh
dying of a heart attack oh actively in
labor and the baby's half out oh you
know just
ho-hum i know what to do going about my
job and go home at have dinner with my
family and not think too much about it
that's amazing
i do i do try to maintain you know both
my fascination you know as i think
writers in general tend to think more
about what they see write more about
what they see maybe draw connections
with what they see to other things so i
do think that writer's perspective does
help me
uh kind of maintain my fascination and
my kind of more of an insightful
perspective than just a ho-hum water
cooler conversation
um
but you do see a lot you know
in a way medical problems are sort of
the great equalizer right
class
race culture background you know the
failings of the human body the way it
fails and what we can do to help in
those situations is almost universal
i always like this quote from you know
chekhov was a doctor and a writer and he
saw treated a lot of peasants very low
class and also treated a lot of
aristocrats and he
he wrote that they all have the same
ugly bodies basically which i think is
really
right on and you know it's sort of you
can see people underneath a superficial
layer of clothing maybe it's the most
expensive clothing bought from the
fanciest places but underneath their
body is still failing in the same way
and they still have the same anxieties
the same worry about mortality the same
concerns about whether poop turned green
today
all these things that they bring to the
table so in a way it is this great
equalizer um where people are kind of
all the same in some ways
yeah i feel like people sometimes class
money
fame
power
makes you for time forget that you're
just
a meat vehicle
and um and
just as good and just as bad as the
other meat vehicles
all around you
in that sense
there's this question sometimes raised
are some people better than others
and i usually answer no to that question
because of that yeah some people might
be better at math some people might be
better at music
but at the end we're just meat bags
you